- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter, to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
Bipedal, naked, large-brained, long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here, an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Steven] Where did we come from and how
did we get here? Those are important
questions. The best answer that I can give
you is I came from North Carolina, and I'm
pretty sure it was Delta 1833 last night.
But on behalf of my co-chair, Dr. Phillip
Rightmire, and me, I would like to
welcome you to this symposium on the
origin of the genus Homo. There is
probably no transition in human
evolutionary history which is as
significant as the origin of the genus
Homo. Prior to about two million years
ago, the fossil record tells us that
Africa was largely populated, not
completely populated, but largely
populated with Australopiths. After about
two million, the Australopiths are largely
gone and we have a diverse array of early
members of our genus, and very shortly
after that, we begin to find Homo erectus.
And with Homo erectus, we have a creature
which is in every way different from the
Australopiths, larger in body size, a
different body shape, a larger brain,
adaptations for more efficient
long-distance walking and running,
possibly adaptations in the shoulder for
being able to throw with speed. We see a
shift in dietary ecology, more consumption
of animal tissues, and that's associated
with a much greater dependence on stone
tool use. There are changes in energetics.
There's changes in thermal regulation.
There are likely to be changes in social
organization, reproductive strategies,
life history. I cannot overstate the
importance of this transition in human
evolutionary history. But as important as
this is, it is equally mysterious and
frustrating to those of us who study it.
The fossil record has been fairly scrappy,
and the fossils that we do recover are
diverse.
- And it's very, very difficult to
understand what to make of them. So there
are major questions which still exist.
When did the genus Homo originate? Where
did it originate? From whom did it come?
Where did Homo erectus come from? What
were the evolutionary processes? What were
the environmental conditions, the
ecological circumstances? What was the
genetic background, the molecular
background? What things led to these sort
of profound changes that we see in human
anatomy, human physiology, human behavior,
human ecology? It's a wonderfully rich
area. There have been remarkable fossil
discoveries made in the last decade, or
so. But, with every new discovery, in some
cases it clarifies for us, but more often
than not, it simply adds more depth and
texture to the mysteries that surround the
origin of the genus Homo. I'm really
excited about this workshop today because
we have brought together some of the
leading scholars that work in this area
and I think it's going to prove to be a
very, very interesting and very rewarding
workshop on the origin of the genus Homo.
♪ [music] ♪